right now you can buy a house for less
than it costs you to rent what do i mean
home ownership is a less expensive
option than renting in a majority of u.s
housing markets right now at the moment
even with home prices increasing
significantly by more than 10 most of
the country over the past year this is
still true there's a new study that has
come out the atom data solutions found
that owning a median priced home was
more affordable than the average rent on
a three-bedroom property in 58
of the 1100 u.s counties that they
analyzed we have this great chart here
from freddie mac the primary mortgage
market survey chart and what we can see
is that the factors and all of the
expenses of owning including monthly
mortgage payments property taxes and
home owners insurance still makes it
cheaper than renting in many places so
when you see that mortgage you can see
those mortgage rates right there
starting to tick upwards higher rates
are causing people not to refinance or
take mortgages like they previously were
refinance activity is 40 lower than a
year ago and the volume of mortgage
applications for purchases was 12 lower
than just one week ago and so if we go
ahead and we look at the share of income
spent on housing what you can see here
is homeowners spend a smaller share of
their income on housing as compared to
renters this is true at all income
levels so not only is it more affordable
but you also end up spending a smaller
share of their income on housing and so
why exactly is it still cheaper to rent
in big cities well home ownership is
more affordable than renting in suburban
and rural areas but it's cheaper to rent
in a big city rather than buy so it's
all about where do you live and what is
the type of density in a population we
have this quote here todd tedda the cpo
at adam he said the housing market boom
of the past decade keeps pushing home
values to new records yet homeownership
still remains the more affordable option
for average workers in the majority of
the country because it still takes up a
smaller portion of their pay rising
wages and interest rates around three
percent are enough to offset recent
price run-ups and keep ownership on the
plus side of the affordability ledger
compared to renting
generally i agree with this i don't
think that interest rates are gonna get
to three percent that would be pretty
crazy from about zero percent where we
are today but of course as rates rise in
2022 which is the expectation that is
why risk assets are selling off that
narrative may shift homes will be
cheaper but mortgages will be higher and
so although you can buy a cheaper house
there may be more carrying cost to a
higher priced mortgage and so ultimately
the conclusion you look at this little
scatter plot
of uh geography if you will what you can
see is in each one of these counties
there is either a buy or a rent which
one is more affordable and as you look
into the high densities of the northeast
you can see that it is more affordable
to actually rent rather than buy same
thing all throughout california because
they basically don't care about their
citizens and have absolutely destroyed
their economy and forced people to leave
but then if you look all throughout the
east through the midwest and down into
the southeast outside of south florida
it is actually better to buy rather than
rent now john when you see this data
you rent today i rent joe runs does that
change your mind
yes i mean it's been historically known
that owning a home is better just based
on an equity front you can also use
leverage so in a home
versus just renting and but on the on
the opposite side of the the other
argument of it is that you can use that
down payment to actually put money into
the market like if you can get a better
return somewhere else rather than just
the appreciation of your home then it's
better to do that but on a long term
basis i've always agreed that it is
better to own a home than rent a home um
but it also all depends on like the
individual's financial situation and
what their long-term goals are
joe yeah i don't think uh this is like
very
i don't think this is like new news
right i think uh most people understand
that owning a home was
more beneficial from a cost perspective
given you're getting equity in it you're
taking a mortgage out you can reduce
costs in certain different ways and
parts of it are tax deductible so i
think that most people are renting um or
just in the circumstance where housing
prices have increased too much and they
don't have the ability to go do it
currently i think that they know that
they're probably not getting the value
that they would through a house right
you're not unless you're renting to own
that property then you're not actually
getting anything for other than a place
to live in most cases so i think that
this isn't necessarily new uh but it's
interesting to see the data nonetheless
one thing to point out in this survey is
that
it is i it is cheaper to rent than it is
to buy a home in a lot of areas that are
like 500 000 people or less so like
smaller suburban areas but it's still
cheaper to rent than to buy a home in
major metropolitan areas or cities that
have 500 to a million or a million plus
residents um just based off the data
well i think there's different reasons
for it too like
someone can rent because they cannot
afford a home someone can rent because
they cannot afford the home that they
want someone can rent because they think
home prices are too expensive or
properties are overvalued uh relative to
where they should be some people might
rent because they think a crash is
coming some people may rent because
they're moving somewhere and they don't
know if they're going to stay there long
term some people may rent because they
don't know what area they want to live
in right there's my point is there's a
million different reasons why someone
may rent and a lot of that
ends up
a lot of that ends up people end up
taking a hit when it comes to like the
actual return on their investment
relative to what a house would give them
versus just putting money into a rental
payment every month
for that flexibility and renting
obviously provides you a lot more
flexibility than owning a house um so i
think when it comes to that like there's
a million different reasons why it's
possible but i think the general idea is
most people understand hey with a home
you're you're paying a mortgage every
month you're able to leverage that value
buy something and create equity versus a
rent payment where you're someone else
owns that and is benefiting from you
paying their mortgage
the other piece i think that people have
to just uh wrap their heads around is
it's not just about the cost of what
you're buying as john talked about
there's the leverage components uh but
also um you know one of the big things
that we've all realized as much as we
joke around about new york and miami is
that the miami rental process uh the
market uh the way that the landlords
operate is completely different than new
york in new york there's no there's no
like nonsense right it's like look we
got our lease
give us your information you sign the
lease you get in don't talk to me and
you're good to go the apartment works in
miami these people are wild it out
there's no rent controls they literally
do whatever they want
they just randomly call you and like i
need to come to the unit like there's
all kinds of nonsense that goes on in
miami in new york none of that happened
so i do think that along with it though
is pretty much every building in new
york operates on a somewhat standardized
uh thing is you know what questions to
ask how much does it cost to rent per
month what is there if i buy it how much
is it what's the hoa you know it uh all
that type of stuff here in miami each
building's different as well and so i
think that uh one of the things that new
york has going for in terms of the
experience there's a lot of
standardization there's a lot of
kind of the city telling uh the
landlords what they've got to do and how
to structure some of this stuff and then
the rent controls you know we talked
about it every person i know that moved
to miami a year ago now their landlords
are like yeah we're going to increase
rents 20 percent
like whoa okay that that didn't really
seem like it's very affordable
yeah but home prices are up 20 so maybe
it's the same thing